that's gonna save the universe the light
darkness sunsets on Infinite Earths The
CW's crossover event begins Sunday
December 8th welcome back everyone it's
Charlie we have the official crisis on
Infinite Earths trailer we'll bring it
down there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs there's a new round of that flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be subscriber and leave your
best theory about how crisis ends on the
video they also released the official
synopsis for the first three episodes so
we know when certain people are showing
up because I know a lot of you are like
when is Tom Wellings Superman going to
appear which episode is he going to be
in we have all that information so
starting with the footage the trailer
opens with the footage from what seems
like the first episode I'm assuming it's
gonna be the Supergirl episode and picks
up right after another earth has been
wiped out they cut the trailer in a
really misleading ways so the order of
the scenes in the trailer is not the
same as the order that they happen in
the actual episodes so you have to
assume that this is happening somewhere
during the first episode it looks like
they're in her version of the de oh so
I'm assuming that either her earth
doesn't get wiped or they just watched
another one get wipe but it sounds like
they have a bunch of monitors tracking
all that stuff because they show you the
crazy graphics with different earths
getting wiped out they have that cool
scene of the two different berries
talking to each other you have Barry
Allen Grant Gustin from earth one and
then the John Wesley Shipp Barry Allen
from Earth 90 talking to each other
about one earth per second being wiped
out which adds up to a crap-ton of
earths meaning that there's no way that
we're actually gonna visit every single
one of these they get wiped a lot of
them will probably just watch get wiped
out on a computer board with crazy
graphics most of the mains assembling
and the wreckage of some building after
a fight there's a lot of footage from
this wrecked building in the outside
streets so it sounds like there's some
big battle that happens here it's not
really clear who else they're gonna be
fighting besides the anti-monitor
because he's powerful enough to fight
them all by himself but he does have his
own minions and that might be where
reverse-flash
in because in the old version of Nora's
future newspaper last year there was a
passage that read that reverse-flash was
last seen during crisis leading an army
of shadow demons so even though they've
changed the timeline already they might
twist that a little bit and do a version
of that during the next couple of
episodes of crisis but like you look at
Sarah here if she's clearly fighting
someone with her staff weapon and it's
probably not the anti-monitor
they'll probably address him really
quickly - you know you have three
different versions of Superman that are
gonna show up during this at any given
time if you didn't know who the
anti-monitor was and you were new to
comics you'd probably just assume that
they would fix all your problems so
Superman he's so powerful you have three
of them who can be three versions of
Superman the anti-monitor is one of
those people it's sort of like the
beginning of Avengers infinity war a
situation where you have Thanos beating
the crap out of Thor he killed Heimdall
and Loki then beat the crap out of the
Hulk without his armor on or any weapons
just to show you how powerful he was so
that for the rest of infinity war an
avengers endgame you knew that he was a
threat to the combined forces of the
Avengers so same thing probably gonna
happen right at the beginning of crisis
so all the heroes know what a threat the
anti-monitor is most of them don't even
know that he exists yet they just know
that something dangerous is coming and
the monitor has not fully explained that
to them yet
so everyone leave your predictions if
they're gonna kill someone at the
beginning of crisis to make the
anti-monitor feel like a big fan of
level villain who do you think that he's
going to kill because it sounds like it
might be this version of Superman with
the torn cape blowing in the wind is
right out of the death of Superman comic
right after he was killed by doomsday it
makes sense that they would pay
reference to that and use it for a big
beat-down moment to show how badass the
anti-monitor is then you see a version
of Batman's suit with cobwebs all over
it it's the same suit that Batwoman
wears so it's not clear if this is on
earth one orifices some other earth but
Kevin Conroy speaking of older Batman
did explain what's going on with his
version of Batman during the crossover
he said the version of his character is
supposed to be way darker than Batman
Beyond old Bruce Wayne so that's
probably why they went for more of a
Kingdom Come angle with that special
harness that he wears like Kingdom Come
Batman if you've never read that
storyline the reason why that version of
Batman is different is because Bane and
a bunch of other super villains
eventually come and destroy Wayne Manor
and Bruce Wayne just retreats and starts
living out of the Batcave and because
his body has become so broken he has to
wear the harness but he's also become so
cynical that when Superman kingdom comes
Superman comes back to recruit him for a
new version of the Justice League that's
gonna reform he agrees to help them out
but he refuses to join the new leak
that's how cynical he is he has this
army of mechanical Batman robots to
patrol the streets I don't know if
they're gonna do Kingdom Come Easter
eggs if they're gonna do Easter eggs for
the Batman robots the CW doesn't really
have that much money so I'm not
expecting them to do it but it would be
pretty cool there's this giant structure
behind Superman and Supergirl that looks
way more advanced and different from the
architecture of the lobby that they're
all standing in and all this wreckage so
this might have something to do with the
monitors cosmic tuning forks from the
comics these devices that he's trying to
build that's part of the reason why he's
been sending Oliver in the arrow people
around collecting all this technology
speaking of which if you're wondering
why Mia is walking around all over the
place
in these shots with Oliver it's probably
because the producers want to put her in
front of your face as much as possible
to hype up the spin-off show that
they're doing for arrow next year then
Sara shows up Lila is inside a version
of the de o on super girls earth it's
not clear if this is earth 38 but the
reason why the sky is red is because the
color of the antimatter wave whenever it
comes for a planet to wipe it out it's
red so maybe super girls earth is right
on the brink of getting wiped out
because she keeps talking about losing
the planet we can still save people but
the planet is lost then we finally sees
Smallville Superman Tom Welling on his
earth on his Kent farm just doing chores
he looks super surprised to see who
shows up
notice the correctly colored blue sky
behind him because pariah Welles in the
shot right after this is on a different
earth on another farm with a completely
different looking orange cast sky behind
him the reason why they do that on the
TV shows is to let you know when you go
to a different earth so whichever
version of Superman pariah Welles goes
to visit on his Kent farm it's a
different version it might wind up being
Kingdom comes Superman then everybody
goes to get black lightning in this very
dungeon II looking room which also has a
cosmic treadmill this might be somewhere
where earth 90 flash has been working
out of because there's all this really
advanced technology that
doesn't look like something out of black
lightnings TV show and this treadmill is
exactly like the one the Barry ran on
the first couple of seasons on the flash
hopefully they'll finally turn the
regular just really souped up advanced
treadmill into the comic book cosmic
treadmill on the TV shows that would be
really bad ass Barry gets thrashed
around if you freeze-frame this shot
funny Easter Egg from behind the scenes
just the making of all this stuff
because they aren't finished with all
the effects you can see that this is
grant gustin's stunt double it's not
actually him in the costume then the
monitor seems like he finally explains
to them what's really going on the fate
of the entire multiverse we got our
first real footage of the John Kent
Superboy who's also going to be a
character on the Superman TV show next
year but their living room has a very
Kryptonian look about it it's also not
clear if this is just temporary or if
this will also show up on that Superman
TV show and this is where they'll live
then you have Kingdom comes Superman
laying some wisdom on them on the
Waverider
no sign of Ray Palmer in the background
I haven't seen any footage or pictures
or behind the scenes where you have Ray
Palmer and Kingdom Come super man
Brandon Roth together on screen Barry
trying to pull off a long jump high in
the air using the building to achieve
takeoff velocity the Waverider arriving
and flying over the city
then Supergirl talking about how they've
lost the earth but they can save a bunch
of other people and Oliver screaming
that it's not time yet so it's a bunch
of different scenes all put on top of
each other then they repeat the scene
where Barry watched himself die during
crisis really is him turning into pure
Speed Force energy just like Barry did
in the comic book crisis on Infinite
Earths but here's the full official
synopsis for the first three episodes so
episode one goes like this in
preparation for the impending crisis
with their worlds in imminent danger the
superheroes suit up for battle while
Martian Manhunter and Alex recruit Lena
Luthor to help them find a way to save
the people of Earth thirty-eight than in
Episode two this is the one where Tom
Welling shows up the synopsis says the
group uses Ray Palmer's invention to
track new recruits to help save the
universe which is obviously where they
find themselves on Smallville's earth
with Tom Welling Superman the monitor
sends iris Clark and Lois in search of a
mysterious Kryptonian who probably is
Tom Welling Superman while Kate in car
ahead to find Bruce Wayne that's Kevin
version of Batman and in addition Mia
challenges Sarah
heatwave discovers a hidden talent and
Lex Luthor Jon Cryer's Lex Luthor
returns then episode 3 starts with
pariah Wells and listing black
lightnings helped to stop the
anti-monitor after earth 90 flash John
Wesley ships flash shares what he
learned from his battle in Elseworlds
last year with the help of Black
Lightning Barry Cisco and killer frost
come up with a plan that could save them
all while Oliver and Diggle return to an
old familiar stomping ground we'll get a
bunch more trailers after this so don't
worry I'll just break those down as they
release more footage next up is part 1
of the Flash's two-part Miss season
finale so my video for that will post
real soon
but everyone click here for that new
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 3 video
in every one click here for all my other
crisis on Infinite Earths trailer and
teaser videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]